I told you at the top of the show
no industry is going to be left
untouched by Pride that is true even of
the abortion industry here is the pride
campaign for Planned Parenthood
hi hi
my name is lucky I've had an abortion
and I get gender affirming care from
Planned Parenthood
I wound up in a very very difficult
relationship and within three months I
found out that I was pregnant I was like
oh no
my abortion was one of the greatest acts
of compassion I had ever committed it
was an easy decision and it was a
decision that for the friends I had told
I was trans they were like get it you
know that's fine like great you know
that's your decision you want to finally
begin your life and it was
just one of the best decisions I had
ever made
ever in my life
who's she trying to convince
the lady doth protest too much me thinks
when you make a good decision
do you need to constantly tell yourself
and everybody else what a good decision
that was
when you engage in behaviors that are
good for you and that allow you to
flourish
do you need to change your name to lucky
I don't know what her real name is but
do you need to change your name to Lucky
happy fortunate oh me I'm happy that's
my new name I used to be Michael but now
I'm happy because of how happy I am I'm
so happy it was I've made all the best
decisions I don't have any regrets no
not me no I'm so happy are the cameras
rolling yes I'm still very very happy
I'm not really persuaded by that
I'm not persuaded this poor woman
[Music]
maybe if I just do one more video for
Planned Parenthood about how happy I am
maybe then I'll really be happy
does that look like a flourishing person
I don't think so and then Planned
Parenthood posts this with a comment
says
when it comes to your abortion any
reason is the right reason
gives away the game right there telling
your abortion story is important and the
more we talk about this essential form
of Health Care the more normalized it
becomes thank you for sharing lucky it
it does become somewhat more normalized
it does become somewhat more accepted
that's true that's how culture works
but it never becomes good it never
becomes right it can never totally shut
out
the moral conscience
we know most of maybe all of us know at
some level but most of us now a pretty
visceral level this is really wrong and
you can normalize it and you can put
rainbows on every single building and
you can have planned parenthood ads
blaring from all the TV screens
you can't change that reality you can't
shut out that the Beating Heart
underneath the floorboard in the Edgar
Allan Poe story you can't
That's The Telltale Telltale Heart
that's the The Telltale
moral conscience that you've got that
that's going to that's that's going to
show you the truth right now go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles living a healthy lifestyle is
not always easy especially when you're
always on the go you need simple
manageable routines to make sure you're
getting the proper nutrition every day
which is why I'm a huge fan of balance
of nature balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to ensure you're
getting essential nutritional
ingredients daily their capsules are
packed with 100 whole food that you can
take at any time balance of nature uses
a cold vacuum process that preserves the
natural phytonutrients in whole fruits
and vegetables and encapsulates them for
easy consumption balance of nature sent
a bunch of their products down to the
studio for our team to try and these
dirty rotten Jackal hyenas just took all
of them they just pounced they just
pounced and they restored balance to
their bodies but it was sometimes
difficult to claw over them and get get
them for me too go to
balanceofnature.com right now use promo
code nullskin wlas for 35 off your first
order is a preferred customer that is
balanceofnature.com promo code Knowles
for 35 off your first order
right now go to cinch.com use promo code
Knowles you picture that perfect summer
night you imagine the warm breeze on
your face as you Lounge in your favorite
chair outside the grill is sizzling with
those Juicy Burgers the aroma of food is
irresistible your mouth Waters as you
wait for it to be cooked to Perfection
now
imagine what this perfect summer night
would have looked like if you went to
turn on the grill and your propane tank
was empty
that's where our friends at cinch come
in cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
grill tanks right to your door cinch
delivers on your schedule and requires
no long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere go online to cinch.com or
download the Cinch app to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for just 10 bucks with promo
code Knowles kwles cinch.com download
the Cinch app promo code nulls to get
your first tank exchange for just 10
bucks limited time offer you must live
within a cinched service area to redeem
it cinch cynch.com offer for details
any reason is the right reason for an
abortion any reason
any reason what if it's that you hate
men you hate men
and you found out that your baby is a
boy and so you want to kill the the baby
boy because you hate men so much that is
actually an acceptable reason for an
abortion now and people do it and
doctors perform it
what if it's this what if it's that you
hate black people and you you know
you've got your you have you're a woman
you have sex with a black person and so
you know your baby's going to be black
and you just you you hate black people I
mean you really I don't know maybe you
got too drunk one night you slept with
this but you really you seriously hate
black people so you found out your kid's
black and so you wanna you wanna kill
your child because he's black and you
want to kill a black person
that could be a reason for an abortion
would that be the right reason according
to Planned Parenthood that would because
any reason is the right there's no wrong
wrong reason to have an abortion
what if you want to have an abortion
because you believe as many many people
throughout history have believed that
there are demons and you can Curry favor
with Demons by sacrificing uh innocent
people and especially sacrificing babies
widespread practice throughout the
entire world for most of human history
including today by the way
would that be a good reason that's a
good reason to uh yes I want to have an
abortion to uh Curry favor with the dark
lord of the Netherworld would that be a
good reason according to Planned
Parenthood would I know it sounds
ridiculous to many modern people that's
what they're saying
the reasons always change the conclusion
is always the same kill your baby
when any argument can lead you to a
certain
conclusion a certain dark conclusion
that should throw up your warning signs
that should have the sirens blaring whoa
watch out here we're not dealing with
reality this is not logical there's dark
stuff going on
and you're seeing it throughout the left
any any reason is a reason to sterilize
yourself and chop off your genitals and
pump yourself full of poison any reason
is good or whether you think you're born
that way you think you became that way
or you watched a bunch of porn or
whatever it is any reason just trans
yourself just castrate yourself
just chop your body up just kill your
baby
the voice that is speaking to you and
telling you that that's not the voice of
the Holy Spirit that's not the voice of
your moral conscience that's a very
different voice and it's a voice that
you should block out
might be it might be multiple voices
might be a legion of voices some some
might suggest boy what a great clip that
was make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time